hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a Good Wife now because
I'm an utter idiot and you guys need to
point this out to me
I didn't play these games in the right
order a good wife comes out before a
good husband now I don't know if the
story is actually pertaining from one to
another but I guess it's gonna follow
the same themes I'm gonna be incredibly
depressed at this failed marriage and an
example of how societies degrading oh
boy I love the controls here I also love
my blocky dress where's my dinner woman
yes my name is woman it's Danish I guess
because I'm a Danish wife plucked from
the streets of Danish land not
Deutschland because that's Germany but
I'm as Danish woman feed my man I whoa
did I get a little heart I could kiss
him on the cheek it was not bad vis off
your way better start than the other
ones my goodness my man loves me and I
love cooking for my man my Danish meals
from my land of Danish land oh what a
good dream this is to be a date is not a
date sex in it any particular means but
uh oh good year it is to live the
perfect life of being a good wife to my
nan Danish husband don't ask me how I
got to this place and point in time oh
oh I grabbed my husband a beer
he loves my not bad meals Oh over the
cat across my hopes and dreams but oh oh
this Danish woman doesn't mind because
the dough
oh okay the Danish woman lovely in me
that is me that I am loves to do the
goddamn decide shut up I'm sorry on my
Danish friends well what do you what are
you Dutch nuts of course god dammit the
Dutch Danish oh I'm so offensive right
now ah plagues gave them just offending
everyone across the start
this is neva titania Saxon it's more
like a a soft Irish Scottish accent
mixed with a little bit of Canadian but
I don't know would I know I need to fill
my man with love by kissing a man among
the back of it the nape of his neck
everybody stop looking at me like that
boom
my man loves me my man loves me and I
love my man no one can say bad [ __ ]
about my man being my man is at the top
of my food chain and apparently he's an
insatiable appetite and I'm just feeding
him to League dudes I'm guessing the
hunger points and love meter are of him
and not of me because I'm already filled
with as much love as I could handle cuz
everyone is filled with this accent as
much as they can handle would be oh I
need to shut up I really I don't know
what's going on with today
but today is not a good day for me to
record videos oh one more meal oh one
more meals for my loving husband let me
get a pair oh is that for you do you
like my cooking with you that I do not
for you but with you oh whatever but
that's okay I don't mind that back up to
100 wool cameras a little problem oh my
man love my muffins my muffins are a
tasty muffins when all of Joycelyn
danish land dutch or can i lift the seat
up and down when am I gonna move off
from the Saxon diggable
Oh naked my blocky bosom is exposed for
the entire audience out there see I
don't know why I'm playing this game I I
wonder I really wonder if the ending is
gonna be the same way as the other one
because I imagine I mean I haven't run
across any place where I could have a
flashback just like the other one that I
was thinking that was a gun oh oh here's
the gun oh good I'm so happy but I just
need to fill my man with love and
everything will be fine everything's
gonna be just fine I don't think yeah I
guess he could do without a meal I mean
I've stuffed himself all day I don't
know how he can fit anymore in his
gullet can i watch TV or something
I wish TV okay now I see who - who the
what the hell what was that and also
what was the noise that I made I don't
know I was the middle of doing my Danish
I said yeah and it just gotta came out
as a whoo-hoo
I don't know why I'm still clutching my
chest not that my heart hurts or
anything but I'm just trying to hold in
all the love that I feel for my husband
here people told me that in a good
husband there was another way to end the
game wait is there like yeah like they
said that I could have left her in any
timer after I got like a thousand points
so I'm gonna try to get a thousand
points
BRB I'm gonna do it with extreme kissa
tude Oh do you feel my Danish love well
safe danger oh do you feel my Danish of
my love it's bad okay
goddamn that's gotta be annoying for
birds and dogs whoa jeez I'm hurrying as
fast as I can I'm a kiss I'm a kissing
fiend who I really question how I'm
giving this love my arms are getting
tired
oh-oh I got a ding what does that mean I
got to a thousand points I got a ding
my husband's almost out of food in his
face so I better stuff him with more
really great food for him
anus cooked and everydayness girl's
dream is to get a thousand points and
get that ding cuz I already got the ring
left hand I have no idea I guess it's
either a choice between getting the gun
or leaving could I get the gun and leave
I don't know I kind of want to stop I
kinda want to keep it to the same theme
you know I'm obviously a rampaging
psychopath and everyone out there knows
I'm completely out of my mind
so why not I don't know oh god what ask
husband for a favor
what what what is that my prize for
getting a thousand points I'd love to
shoot him everyone's happy
oh yes oh it's for everybody
a Danish girls other dream is a for his
heart beer husband do her mom just a
little Jewish I don't think anything
that I said was just appropriate for
anybody yay it's a happy ending literal
happy ending oh boy all you gotta do is
feed your man till he explodes and then
kiss him on the ear until it falls off
and he hates you for it and then you get
your cookie so anyway that was a good
wife thank you all so much for watching
I'm so glad you could join me for this
crazy adventure and frankly turn out a
lot better than the other one so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
my
oh you're great I smell bad I also have
to go in the bathroom don't mind the
owner